the mass singer season 5 is well
underway and in last night's episode we
got our very first look at the group
b performers sadly we did have to say
goodbye to the phoenix who couldn't
quite rise from the ashes
[Applause]
yes caitlyn jenner on the masked
singer not exactly someone that i would
expect to go on this show
but my favorite performers historically
have been people who are
you know completely out of the
performing or the singing wheelhouse and
watching caitlyn take a risk step
outside her comfort zone and try this
i was super super here for it how did
you feel listen we thought kermit the
frog was a twist from group a caitlyn
jenner
singing kesha's tick tock in group b
again not expect it but i'd like to
point out we are technically one degree
away from having a kardashian on the
show which i'm obsessed with
other than the phoenix who was your pick
of the night deidre my absolute top pick
of the night
was the piglet
now i think the piglet is former
bachelor peter
weber let me explain so the whole clue
package
was doused in roses and we even got to
see
a home or a mansion which looked very
very similar to
traditionally the bachelor mansion and
then if we want to talk about a few
specific clues
we heard the piglet talk about how he's
given out a few roses and the world
watched my heart break and if we think
back to peter webber's journey with love
well he started with hannah brown then
he went to hannah ann
then he went to maddie pruitt and most
recently
kelly flanagan so he definitely has
shown that he falls fast and he falls
easily in love
we also saw a clue of a tattoo heart
with an
axe going through it if you think back
to peter's season on the bachelor
you'll remember a very famous date he
went on with hannah ann
which involved axe throwing listen i
love peter webber and i do hope it's him
under that mask because it had a great
voice and i
really really did enjoy the performance
my pick of the night however is the
black swan
now i think the black swan is pop
superstar jojo
not jojo siwa who we saw on a previous
season of the mass singer but the pop
star jojo herself now in the clue
package we heard them say
hypnotized by a hollywood deal she could
not resist
unfortunately jojo was very open about
being stuck in her recording contract
for over
seven years with blackground
entertainment which leads me into the
next part of the clue where she said
my faithful flock flew to my rescue and
set me free
i'm in control now jojo in 2014 was
finally
released from that record label and she
is now able to put out her own music
which is why i'm kind of thinking she
alluded to that almost trapped feeling
in her clue package
we also saw one more thing in there we
saw a large x on the ground
that x could be referring to jojo's
guest appearance as a guest judge
on the x factor celebrity edition in
2019.
well the competition on the mass singer
is just starting to heat up
of course you heard who charlie and i
think is behind the mask
but really guys we love hearing from you
continue to tweet us continue to dm us
on instagram
because at the end of the day we're all
one team and we're looking to crack that
code
there is still so much guessing to be
done and just like the mass singer has
always said
be safe and wear a mask